ça va ils ratent pas sur la route est
content
juste il faut que vous du phase de
petite pause d'un an
mais là on fait ça juste pour la caméra
parce que hip hop là et à trop
d'animations les endroits qui connaît
pas et tu essaies façon c'est pas
s'embêter à
l'embellir au
passé trouble c'est peut-être son délire
fait j'ai peur
attention mon nom
mais non il est super cool désolé je
ferme telle est baladé dans la voiture
j'aimerais bien pouvoir me balader avec
lui en laisse comme si c'était un chien
vert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà je viens tu montes l'instru un
petit peu il est quelle heure
8h15 beaucoup trop tôt
regarde la nostalgie leur faire miroiter
la grandeur d'une france passé qu'ils
ont fantasmé regard de l'incompréhension
saisir ceux qui voient leur foi dénigrer
sans qu'ils aient réellement des avocats
la peur est persuadé que les étrangers
vont bien dans leur salon pour les
remplacer tu me parce qu'on est donc on
est là sur ce pardonne jamais dans un
monde aurait un s'efface on sera chez un
seul ace d'autres on sait pas vivre
ensemble ou qu'on se bat pour être à
l'avant dans un avion qui va droit vers
le crash ça va tu veux l'attentât ça va
c'est extraordinaire
c'est que sam et dean et
villaret c'est incroyable à vie avec
l'émotion cantat c'est super beau bamako
c'est un vrai truc j'avais vraiment peur
j'ai pas eu le temps de répéter est
toujours dehors j'ai conscience aussi
deux chez qu'on joue à peu de la folie
du truc mais j'ai peu sa soeur
merci puisque l'album est dingue du coup
droit de la mer serge
july 30 jours non c'est pas que je
voulais pas jouer c'est que en fait je
n'ai jamais répétées
et en fait je suis sur plein de trucs en
même temps heureusement hier et à j'ai
fini je crois à minuit et donc du coup
j'avais j'ai jamais vraiment répéter
donc une bi zoua ce serait bien qu'il
fasse un truc que tu as jamais fait et
je flippais en fait tout simplement et
enfin je flippais jeudi ouailles à la
vidéo qui va être sur internet
donc du coup mais moi mon fils à mon
réflexe sera toujours d'avoir la flemme
peux toujours me poussez un peu apprécié
content de l'avoir fait on va au move à
faire une interview pour la sortie de
l'album
comme un peu ce que vous allez voir
toute la journée
l'important
c'est
qu'on va tellement censuré votre montage
route non on va pas censurer comme vous
le croyez c'est juste parce que je faire
des blagues pas drôles et qu'on va aller
couper
ça va ouais ça roulait
sur les sorties
comment s'appelle le cinoche et de place
à la soirée chiffres ah oui
c'est plus à qui on dit bonjour avec les
mains
salut mais non mais je suis fou ça y est
c'est le moment où chicago
c'est vous qui faites les missions là
c'est vous qui parlez moi je suis là
pour vous regardez vous parlez tous mes
jeux j'interviens pas
l'idée voilà je vous ai écrit le petit
truc de début
mais c'est juste non pas du tout pas du
tout c'est vraiment c'est vous qui le
fabrique et compétent suis avec vous
mais ouais carrément
ça veut dire beaucoup de méthode je vais
y aller à fond quand on enregistre avec
pharrell à hérouville saint clair
avec qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bien des
chaussures
c'est fou cette émission il n'ya pas
d'animateur salut tout le monde serait
le sann vous êtes en train d'écouter
france inter et je suis venu vous pour
aller de mon nouvel album qui s'appelle
civilisation en fait pour parler de
l'album impôt global les morceaux sont
pas sont pas au hasard je veux dire j'ai
vraiment fait j'ai vraiment fait un
ordre fin on a vraiment fait un autre
parce qu'à un moment on a vraiment mis
bas comme on fait j'en sais trop d'amis
des post it sur le mur avec les titres
des morceaux et on s'est dit ouais ça
est ce que c'est la m en fait j'avais
vraiment réfléchi préfère mettre les
morceaux dans dans un ordre précis et
pour moi l'odeur de l'essence il arrive
derrière parce que ie la manif et parce
que le perso à a traversé ans procès
avoir eu cette prise de conscience et
ils arrivent à un stade de ras-le-bol
ces moments où j'ai occupé à montchat il
y avait toute une au regard du père et
mon 4 passes 4 moteurs du compte qu'on
partait à caen mais qu'en fait
à la ville en été il peut pas rester
tout seul et du coup on dirait vraiment
le gros lot avec son animal mais c'est
çà
et là il vient avec nous à caen
voilà
hmm mousasi samassa moureilles bien
connu
ici ils ont des sandwichs en triangle
d'un cru
alimentation à base de s'enregistrer en
alimentation et tabac aux deux sens du
style ici ils ont vraiment genre des
sens du jeu qu'on trouve dans aucun
autre station service je plaisante on
est à la bourre on se casse déjà on n'a
pas une très large sélection n'a pas une
très large sélection qui a que du donna
je prends jamais les 3g pas pourquoi les
triples ceux qui sont rangés en trip
c'est un peu bizarre ça le donna club
c'est vraiment pao en fait juste il
faudrait
pas encore vu trop de gens qui ont
écouté l'album better ça me fait plaisir
aurait dû tout pigé menacé en fonction
que d'abord nous sentons une évolution
ouais comme quoi au début tant que
perdure ou le nom de bob way et au fur
et à mesure battue bat pour que tu va
mieux même avec les mains
ouais socialement tu vas mieux
psychologiquement on a l'impression que
tu vas mieux
question de cette revue j'étais basée
sur un rapport qui me représente
j'essaie de faire avancer le
l'histoire donc me ressemblent à ceux
trop savoir merci beaucoup maintenant
merci à toi même une petite surprise
c'est toi
j'ai 15 ans je quitte
c'est cool ça à
l'intérieur il ya forcément
une girafe
et pas déjà là bas j'ai une petite boule
jaune à l'intérieur de loveresse pelle
j'ai peur de ne pas connaître mon texte
alors
j'en fais un
j'en fais un parce qu'en fait j'ai pas
fait le répète je connais pas trop et
morceaux en fait ceux sortis tout à
l'heure je m'en rappelle plus
celle intrigues de la journée est ce que
je sais c'est j'essaye sans le texte
je me suis
levé à défaut la salle ce soir c'était
ma première salle premier vrai concert
fois mais vrai
exactement
ouais mais c'est là au premier
but
en 2003 d'une cape
après peut-être 2005 6 phyto ces crèmes
qui connaît tous evil archives
de la tour en carton qu'on avait mis
en appétit
[Musique]
il est comme ça moi je suis gaudin
vraiment je commence juste après douze
heures de l'essence à battre au maire
bref tout va bien les regards hommes
installent doigts et a joué tous les
sens il faut alors que moi je connais
pas encore très fun radio trois jours
sur notre radio j'étais obligé de venir
j'adore la folie j'ai d'abord la
fumée les paroles samad le cargo
merci beaucoup ce méga désir de clamecy
est ce quelqu'un
c'est super cool merci merci merci
où
j'ai fait des erreurs et genre frais
j'espère juste que ça va les mêmes à
quoi ça sert d'écrire des textes et si
je peux pas dire aux gens que j'ai c'est
combien d'autres oraisons funèbres avant
que le tir à prendre un ton père tu dois
france des guerres dont personne sort
gagnant à la fin c'était juste un
passeport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]